hallo leute ich es wieder einmal waren
und willkommen zu einer neuen folge wie
schmeckt und heute machen wir den
erdbeer shake aus riva del hat mich in
den letzten tagen gefühlt eigentlich mal
gefragt ob ich diesen magic machen kann
und ich hab da mal was kleines besorgt
ich habe so lange im internet gesucht
bis ich ein milchglas gefunden habe das
genau oder so fast genauso aussieht wie
das aus übersee und tada ich finde ich
hab echt guten job gemacht mein schädel
und ist mir dagegen nicht ganz so gut
gelungen ich meinen der rote lippenstift
passt schon aber irgendwie ist das
gesamtbild so absolut nicht mein aber wo
gibt es denn nun diesen weltberühmten
milchshake aus riverdale natürlich in
pop steiner der steht nämlich in
riverdale und da hängen die teenager die
ganze zeit aber bei diesen gefühlen die
ich für archie und jack and a bezweifle
ich doch sehr daran dass das teenager
sind
ich glaube die schauspieler sind auch er
in meinem alter also falls jemand
zuschaut
ich bin noch zu haben da ist noch nix da
sollte die serie auch schaut
interessiert es nicht ob der teenager
oder team kannten oder er vielleicht im
bett oder team ronny ich orientiere mich
bei der zubereitung an die fünfzehnte
folge der zweiten staffel da sitzt
nämlich josie und georg jakob steiner
und besprechen wieder irgendein drama
weil es in dieser serie einfach nur
drama gehen ich muss auch ehrlich sagen
dass ich die erste folge gesehen habe
dachte ich so unähnlich schon wieder so
ein film wo alles so super schön sind
und die ganze zeit nur rum machen und
alle sind nur schön und die können nicht
mehr aber mich hat die serie echt
gepackt muss ich sagen ich schaue jedem
woche die neue freude außer wenn da ein
bisschen länger pause
[Musik]
da sitzen sie dabei cops und man sieht
schöne aufnahmen von diesen milchshake
ich sehe da streusel obendrauf
schlagsahne eine erdbeere süß an die
seite gestellt mein perfekt nach
gekauftes glas natürlich in meiner brust
aufnahmen sieht man auch dass der erbe
geschickt und ein bisschen mehr pink ist
und oben mehr voser ich glaube würde das
ist so weil die während der dreharbeiten
ja die ganze hätte sitzen und dann setzt
sich wahrscheinlich die erdbeere ab weil
sich schwerer ist als alles andere ich
habe keine ahnung aber gut leute es ist
sommer wir haben uns eine abkühlung
verdient und machen jetzt gab's milch
shake shake braucht man natürlich mit
erdbeeren eine baustelle vor der haustür
als creme war habe ich joghurt eis
gekauft weil ich finde bonbon vanille
passt mir nicht so den milchshake rein
es ist ja eher einsame 1 was die so in
amerika essen also dieses softeis das
weiße und ich finde joghurteis passt
super gut so erfrischenden
erdbeergeschmack deshalb ihr könnt
natürlich auch das alles nehmen was euch
am besten springen
kommen wir nun zu meiner geheim zutat
aaron zero in den riverdale gibt's ja
ganz viele aaron bäume und die familie
blossom sind ja richtige babas im ahorn
sirup geschäft und deshalb dachte ich
was machen die im modell anstatt zucker
rhein mosel doping gibt es natürlich
zucker streubel milchshake was für ein
zufall ich hab mir da
was brauchen wir für unseren milchshake
natürlich wieder eine maschine das ist
eigentlich ein smoothie make aber wir
müssen ja die rp zuerst sollten wir
unsere erdbeeren waschen und schneiden
doch vorher müssen wir mit einer
heiligen aus bei zeremonie die erdbeere
aussuchen die es an den glasrand schafft
es ist die hier wir haben unsere glas
erdbeere gefunden
sie möge nun wegtreten also ich bin ja
immer sehr sparsam mit dem strom
deswegen einfach oben damit einem messer
lange das dauert uns jetzt aber viel zu
lange also speed up
[Musik]
jetzt ist mir aber gerade was
eingefallen und zwar werde ich nicht von
anfang an alle erdbeeren dar einpacken
weil wir wollen hier genau diesen rosa
ton hinbekommen und einmal drin alles
weg deswegen machen wir es mal so die
hälfte zum teil als zweite zutat kommt
jetzt arrondierung bruder schussmann
sollen ja auch schmeckt und in amerika
ist alles super so jetzt auch natürlich
ein guter schuss milch und jetzt kommt
das 1 wir müssen dieses glas füllen
so jetzt machen wir den deckel drauf
habe ich alle zutaten drin ja power
es hat die perfekte farbe ich glaube wir
brauchen aber ja leute es gibt auch
schnelle wie schmeckt und einfach nicht
schmeckt mein gott er riecht so viel hab
damit in euer glas ich finde in einem
guten milchshake gehört auch noch ein
ganz kleiner verein einfach pferd also
obendrauf geehrt wird lecker so
beschäftigt dass aufgrund bisschen ab
wie bei popstars einfach so seit ich
rein
er sieht es so aus jetzt ist es jetzt so
jetzt die streusel ihr habt es gewollt
hier ist der hawks michelle habe leider
keine strohhalme das ist mir vorhin
aufgefallen und nun steht uns natürlich
wieder der allerwichtigsten frage wie
schmeckt pops er bei milchshake aus der
serie riverdale mein gott ich werde mich
mit dem ding habe ich jetzt warm und
klar ich werde mich gleich ausziehen und
nicht mit denen dinge auf meinem balkon
sitzen und einfach nur diesen schönen
warmen tag genießen leute macht euch
einen leckeren rp shaikh selbst auf
frischen erdbeeren es lohnt sich total
schmeckt super und wie lange hat das
jetzt gedauert fünf minuten absolute
empfehlung und der ahorn sirup eine gute
idee wenn es wieder gefallen hat dann
wie immer daumen nach oben glock
aktivieren abonniert dividieren
schreibt mir die kommentare was wir als
nächstes machen soll
ich hoffe ich konnte jetzt euren bund
spart erfüllen damit und sage ich
tschüss bis zum nächsten mal
hier sind noch zwei weitere videos dabei
sein